ich werde versuchen mich in diesem video
durch vernünftige aktien trades näher zu
einer rolex zu arbeiten viel spaß in
einem meiner letzten videos bin ich
durch eine 800 euro misery box bis auf
1575 euro hoch gekommen
jetzt habe ich mich gefragt wie kann ich
daraus möglichst schnell mehr geld
machen und nach ein bisschen überlegen
habe ich mich für aktien entschieden
einige von euch hatten das schon beim
letzten video in die kommentare
geschrieben wenn ihr also weitere ideen
habt was hier in den nächsten folgen
machen könnte dann schreiben wir das in
die kommentare und möglicherweise werde
ich das so machen wo starte ich also
meine suche wo finde ich aktien die
möglichst profitabel sind und wo ich
möglichst sicher sehr schnell sehr viel
geld machen kann natürlich im thread
wall street star wall street maps ist
eingebettet in dem sich die autoren
gegenseitig als autisten umfang in ritas
bezeichnen genau so werden auch die
meisten beiträge eingeleitet und es wird
noch besser
deshalb redet ist eine mischung aus -
und aktien hört sich nicht nach der
besten mischung an meistens geht es hier
ums schnelle geld gehebelte aktien oder
optionsscheine was so ziemlich das
riskanteste ist was man auf dem
aktienmarkt machen kann
ganz grob gesagt handelt man beim hebel
mit geld das einem nicht gehört man
leiht sich quasi geld bei der bank um
damit aktien zu kaufen wie ein
multiplikator der auf die aktie
angewandt wird kauft man eine aktie mit
10er hebel so hat ein prozent
marktbewegungen eine auswirkung von 10%
in beide richtung man kann potenziell
zehnfach so viel gewinnen aber auch
gleichzeitig zehnfach so viel verlieren
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie schlecht ist
ausgehen kann dann schaut euch das video
von papa platte an dass sie in einer
video beschreibung verlinkt habe mit
meinem bruder
was man aber nicht unterschätzen hat der
satellit neben unendlich vielen müll
post zum eames über 1,6 millionen nutzer
und dadurch eine unheimliche kaufkraft
es kommt tatsächlich vor das upgrade
einfluss auf aktien bewegung nimmt indem
sie gemeinsam kaufen oder verkaufen
quasi wie eine institutionelle
einrichtungen mit millionen geldern was
aber viele der trades die vom nutzern
getätigt werden gemeinsam haben ist ein
bestimmter move jolo wie sich schon
vermuten lässt sein komplettes geld auf
ein viel zu riskantes produkt setzen und
darauf hoffen dass es klappt ihr seht
neben schwerlich zu finden aktientipps
die gut begründet darlegen warum welcher
track los geht es hier darum rhein zu
droppen was das zeug hält und höchstes
risiko zu gehen
es wäre also ziemlich dumm und
verantwortungslos unsere hart verdienten
1575 euro wegen reddot post zu
investieren ja scheint also perfekt zu
sein ich werde in den nächsten tagen
also auf wallstreet betz abhängen und
probieren einen aktien zu finden bei der
es sich lohnt sich war kein sich rein zu
stürzen zumindest eine bei der ich
glaube dass sich
das ganze in trays glaube ich aber dass
man dort tatsächlich nützliche
informationen finden kann und das werden
wir probieren zu tun und man muss halt
extrem filtern weil die leute wieder
irgendwas schreiben meistens genauso
dumm sind wie man selber und können so
wenig arrogant aber ganz kurz noch
vorweg aktien sind ein super cool ist
und interessantes thema ich interessiere
mich auch seit jahren dafür aber es ist
natürlich auch gefährlich und man darf
nicht unterschätzen hebel in
optionsscheine und der ganze andere high
risk raum ist für mich absoluter schrott
und wirklich mit casino oder oder
irgendwie glücksspiel zu vergleichen
verstehe den reiz für finanzprodukte und
für schnelles einfaches geld aber es ist
eben nicht einfach und vor allem nicht
schnell wenn der eine gewinnt verliert
der andere so funktioniert das eben das
ist nur eine umverteilung von geld und
mannschaft kein neues geld wenn nicht
das thema wirklich interessiert und ihr
vernünftige informationen haben wollt
dann empfehle ich euch den kanal
finanzfluss absoluter ehrenmann und
ihren kanal schaute vorbei und dort
bekommt ihr vernünftige option und
vielleicht auch tipps was richtige
anlage strategien sind so was was ich in
diesem video machen werde er nicht wie
ich abseits von youtube unterhaltungs
videos investiere und was ich mit meinem
eigenen geld mache das erfahrt ihr im
stream der gerade live ist link ist in
der video beschreibung rein in die
wallstreet batmaz freunde der guten
unterhaltung ein tag ist vergangen und
ich habe tatsächlich etwas gefunden
tatsächlich scheint es momentan so zu
sein dass die tourismusbranche anfängt
wieder zu ruhm sei es weil es einen
impfstoff gibt auf jeden fall ist das
gerade irgendwie am abgehen ich habe
auch gesehen dass die lufthansa aktie
wieder geisteskrank gestiegen ist und
das haben ein paar leute über karneval
gesprochen das ist eine kreuzfahrt aktie
natürlich wie es mittlerweile verstanden
haben sollte werde ich die aktie nicht
einfach so kaufen sondern ich werde sie
hebeln
das ist super hier ist um natürlich
werden wir auch holen also 1575 euro
spot on werden wir einen ball an das ist
eine absolute schande ich würde das
niemals mit meinem eigenen eigenen
persönlichen hart verdienten geld machen
sondern das mache ich für das video
macht das nicht selber aber ich würde
sagen bedrucken rein wir kaufen 8750
aktien zum preis von 18 cent das sind
genau 1575 euro
die aktie hat heute 37 prozent verlust
gemacht was natürlich ein stabiler
einstieg für uns ist also 37 prozent
bedeutet in der richtigen aktie 3,7
prozent aber bei uns ist ja alles mal 10
das bedeutet wenn wir jetzt morgen
wieder auf den startpunkt von heute
kommen würden dann wären was schon 37
prozent plus man kann es nie voraussehen
deswegen werde ich das jetzt einfach die
nächsten tage beobachten und mich melden
wenn es neuigkeiten gibt viel mehr als
warten und hoffen können wir jetzt nicht
küste den gott des talks ich hoffe auf
viele songs wenn das nicht klappen
sollte dann wäre das sehr schlecht weil
dann wäre dieses projekt jetzt hier
beendet aber ich bin david hinrichs habe
extrem viel glück deswegen gehe ich
davon aus dass wir frank profit machen
werden muss man natürlich auch nicht
vergessen hab ich bin jetzt halt
wirklich nicht einfach so rein gedroppt
also ich hab mich wirklich informiert
ich habe zwar den den denkanstoß von
reddot bekommen aber habt dann super
viel geschaut und geguckt macht das sinn
für mich macht das überhaupt sind wird
das in den nächsten tagen möglicherweise
passieren die sterne stehen gut
beziehungsweise die news und alles was
dazugehört ich könnte es mir vorstellen
aber es ist ein spiel mit dem feuer
die aktie unter 19 dollar 18 feld
verlieren wir unser komplettes geld sind
1575 euro einfach so weg
knock-out-zertifikat nennt sich das das
ist wirklich richtig
mal sehen vielleicht haben wir glück
sehen uns wieder wenn wir hoffentlich
ein bisschen profit gemacht haben und
der markt uns gut etwas andere position
heute aber wir sind bei 18 cent
gestartet den jetzt bei 20 cent nach
einem tag das ist der absolute traum
aber ich bin noch nicht bereit aus zu
cachen das reicht mir noch nicht ich
möchte das noch weitergeht ich weiß
selber nicht war nicht zufrieden wir
aber ich stelle jetzt mal eine limit
order ein damit die aktie sich von
selber verkauft werden sie einen
bestimmten wert erreicht wenn ihr euch
fragt was das für ein szenario ist in
dem ich hier gerade sitze genauso sieht
mainstream aus und ich bin auch gerade
live während ihr dieses video guckt wenn
ihr das video guckt genau wenn es
rauskommt check den link in der video
beschreibung kommt vorbei und lasst uns
gemeinsam stream in der nacht von tag 2
auf 3 habe ich dann noch folgendes bild
gemacht die aktie ist geisteskrank
gefallen um 19 39 hatte ich 60 cent pro
anteil verloren und das hat insgesamt
ein minus von 526 euro ausgemacht
theoretisch hätten wir also nur noch
knapp über 1000 euro an wert gehabt und
genau hier haben wir das problem genau
das passiert eben wenn man wall street
betz vertraut und irgendwelche
komischen kreuzfahrt aktien hebelt aber
im besten fall gibt es dafür eine
ziemlich einfache lösung die aktie
halten warten und füße stillhalten ok
anscheinend hat das schlafen meine
probleme gelöst sieben stunden später
sieben stunden schlaf später um 9.19
wache ich auf zu dem preis von 18 cent
und genau das ist der preis bei dem wir
eingestiegen sind das bedeutet null euro
gewinn 0 euro verlust aber ein guter
ausgangspunkt um von da aus dann
vielleicht ein bisschen gewinn zu machen
und der lässt auch nicht lange auf sich
warten sechs stunden weiter nach vorne
steht die aktie bei 25 cent ich konnte
an dem tag leider nicht so viel in
richtung aktien kram drehen denn ich war
im wald mit fritz meinecke und gestanden
um 15 uhr bei 7 cent pro anteil plus mit
611 euro 50 gesteigertem aktienwert
machen wir uns also auf den weg zurück
nach köln
paul junge macht euch bereit für das
große finale springen 24 stunden nach
vorne alles geht super schnell und ich
habe sofort meine kamera auswendig kann
nicht laut reden max ist im raum nebenan
aber meine order hat gegriffen ich habe
alle aktien verkauft bis auf 50 die wir
jetzt über die nächsten folgen noch
halten werden ich habe gerade einen
moment ich hab noch gar nicht geschaut
wieviel ich gemacht habe lege ich habe
innerhalb von vier tagen 67 66,5 prozent
auf meine aktie gemacht
oh mein gott
ich habe ja gerade gesagt dass ich 50
von den anteilen noch drin lasse aber
jetzt ist sie gerade noch mal so weit
gestiegen ich will jetzt auch nicht
gierig werden
ich gehe jetzt raus 83 alter ich
verkauft die sofort ich glaube ich noch
5 250 habe ich noch nicht nur 50 das ist
so gestört dass kann man wirklich
niemandem erzählen
ich spiele im casino ist funktioniert
ich kaufe dem mystery box ist
funktioniert ich hebel eine aktie mit
zehn erhebe
und es funktioniert und nicht nur so ein
bisschen sondern das funktioniert
richtig
okay aber wie viel haben wir jetzt im
endeffekt wirklich verdient insgesamt
stehen wir jetzt bei 2632 euro und 50
cent
vielleicht aber auch nicht aktienkäufe
werden grundsätzlich und bei mir sofort
über den broker steuer das bedeutet
insgesamt stehen wir jetzt de facto bei
2351 euro und 88 cent wir haben uns
wieder um über 800 euro gesteigert das
ist komplett verrückt ich will noch mal
sagen mach das bitte mich mit eurem
eigenen geld ich mache das auch nicht
mit meinem eigenen geld abseits von
diesem video was ich mit meinem geld
mache erfahrt ihr im stream den wir
jetzt anschauen könnt ihr linkes in der
video beschreibung ich hoffe ich habe
das video gefallen wenn ja lass mir leid
da vergesst nicht zu abonnieren damit
ihr die kommenden teile des rolex trade
projekts nicht verpasst wir sehen uns
nächste woche lasst es euch gut gehen
bis dann